This video is sponsored by remote HQ.
Sometimes it's easy to get the whole team together in the same room all the
times you need remote HQ more than the internet.
It sounds like you said the history turns on the smallest is moments.
If that's the case,
then it's hard to imagine a moment smaller than the one that took place in
October the 31st, 15, 17,
that date an obscure angry monk took a list of 95 things he was off about
and nailed it to the door of Wittenberg church. As gestures go, it was dramatic,
but pointless. So provincial stunt,
and one of the unfashionable corners of the Holy Roman empire,
yet it was from these humble beginnings that a series of events emerged that
would shake both Europe and Christianity to that.
Cause that off a monk who was none other than Martin Luther ruins.
His actions were about to spark the reformation,
the eldest child of a launch family with peasant origins,
Martin Luther was living proof of that old adage about some men being born to
greatness while others have greatness thrust upon them all through his early
life. He showed no signs of being anything other than stubbornly ungreat.
But when the time game he would be the one who ushered in a brand new era in
religious history,
It was a storm that did it all the centuries of religious drive,
all the dead of the 30 years war.
None of it could have happened without one area of low pressure forming above
Germany and the summer of 1505 that's because that fateful July day,
a law student in Martin Luther just happened to be walking home.
When the storm broke right about him by all accounts,
there was one of those storms that only appears in fiction full of lashing rain
and apocalyptic lightning, terrifying Luther offered up. They shouted prep.
If the storm ceased,
he would quit his studies and devote himself to God almost immediately.
The wind debated just days later, Luther followed through on his vow.
From that moment on the course of Western Christianity was set.
The reformation was on its way.
The man who had Russia written was born on November the 10th, 1483,
the eldest of nine siblings, although Martin Luther,
his parents were of peasant stock.
Something you used to humble brag about they'd come far from their lowly
origins.
Luther's father Hans had gotten into or refining and managed to build a decent
business. When Lisa was young, Hans was even made town counselor,
not quite ascending to the Elise,
maybe about light years beyond what German peasants could normally dream of.
Thanks do breaks like this.
Martin Luther was able to get an education learning Latin and getting tutored by
an ecclesiastical brotherhood. He did so well.
There's in 1501 homes enrolled in an effort, a university.
Then the top place for brainy dudes to study the plan was for Luther to study
law,
get an awesome job and then drag the family ever further into what then passed
for the middle classes by 1505, Luther had his master's degree.
You had purchased all his materials for the upcoming law course and generally
settled on Zooey.
LifeTrack that guaranteed in both happy parents and us or obscurity.
But then the boy happens to go walking outside in July of 1505 and everything
changed. You already know the story from the cold open,
the lashing rain as you sized lightening bolts, the shouted prayer,
the vow to become a monk just days later via one blazing rout with hands Martin
Luther answered to the monastery of the order of the hermits of St. Augustine.
The Augustinians at this time were split into two factions.
One which believed everything should be as strict and as joyless as possible.
And to one which favored everything being just a less crappy.
This was possibly join us Hoff. The so-called observance faction,
which meant cold rims rising at the crack of Dawn fasting, confessing,
and other incredibly not fun things.
But Lisa took it like an unbaptized doctor, Holy water.
He followed the rules spends this time,
studying theology became almost the platonic ideal of a monk. In fact,
at this stage in his life,
he showed no signs of rebellion or individual thinking at all by 1508.
He was teaching theology at the university of Wittenberg and doing a decent
average job. It would take the crisis of 15,
10 to finally shake him out of his rut that year, Pope Julius.
The second announced that he was going to force the observance and non observant
Augustinians to merge into a single order for Luther's observed and faction.
This was a little like being part of an upright fraternity.
You suddenly told it has to merge with animal house. There was outrage panic,
and Luther's monastery the monks scrambled to find someone to go to Rome and
make their case before the Pope and what you can to guess who they chose in late
15, 10 Martin Luther sat out from Germany for the first time in his life heading
South for Italy,
for the eternal city and the beating heart of Western Christianity.
What he saw when he got that would transform him from a pious average monk into
the most dangerous heritage.
Um.
You ever spent years dreaming of visiting somewhere only for it to turn out,
to be just a bit crap in real life.
While that intense feeling of disappointment was probably only a fraction of
what Martin Luther experienced in Rome arriving at the end of the year,
the monk discovered not a shining Kristy and Citadel button,
moral toilets in Rome. Luther spent time with priests who were openly corrupts,
laughing at their followers.
As they charged extortionate amounts were saying mass.
He was so disillusioned that if humans,
Rome is a harlot and that was before the Pope ignored is pleased to keep the
Augustinian order separate. By the time Luther sloped back to Germany,
he was exhausted depressed, and his faith was deeply shaken,
but it would take several more years before this spiritual torment became
outward action. In the meantime,
Luther settled into a life of teaching in Wittenberg,
then an up-and-coming students down with a new university,
but what's in bag at something else going for it too.
It was a key part of the empass future. At the time,
our story is set Germany as a nation didn't exist.
Instead Europe was straddled by a bam author known as the Holy Roman
empire, a collection of hundreds of States,
principalities Dutchies free cities and random valleys,
somehow wielding political power.
The empire under the Catholic Habsburg rulers considered itself the defender of
European Christianity while the Habsburgs held the post of Holy Roman emperor,
it wasn't hereditary.
Each new emperor had to be chosen by an Imperial council of seven.
This means those on the council,
wielded out signs influenced one of those seven was the Alexa of Saxony
Frederick the wise, although it was Catholic Frederick,
the wise was also a humanist and a relatively free thinker who believes in
outrageous stuff like fair trawls. He was also the guy in charge of belief,
this new home town of Wittenberg,
the elector most openly trying to gain more autonomy from the emperor.
It would be these Chan's qualities that would soon turn Frederick the wise and
to Martin Luther's staunchest protected. But before we get that,
we have to pick out one more thread from this weave that's known as pre
reformation Europe. It's one more thread to add to our threads on Frederick,
the wise, the election system of the Holy Roman empire and Martin Luther's
disillusionment.
It's one more thread that will explain how this John's upheaval managed to
happen. The threads marked indulgences in 1513, Pope Julius,
the second went to meet his maker and was replaced by Leo the 10th. Now Leo,
his whole thing was grandiose projects to fund his grandis the reconstruction of
the Basilica of St. Peter. He issued a new set of indulgences, gets out of jail,
free cards for sin.
Indulgences could be bought the cash and resigned for which the Pope would
absolve you of your mortal sins. Now,
technically you were supposed to both by the indulgence and do some good deeds,
but by 15, 15,
the system had dissolved into rich folks sending away and then paying the church
to ignore it.
Because of this indulgence is pretty controversial among poor people who
couldn't afford to cover as the neighbors all so whatever,
but they were also frowned upon by the aristocracy.
Many German princes felt indulgences,
but just a way for the Pope to shake them down every time he wanted a new
Basilica. So when the fry Johan tenants all started touring,
what is now the East of Germany, shilling Leo, the 10th new cheat cards.
People were primed to react. And here we are,
then I'd lost the moment when all these threads we've been gently talking at are
going to be yanked together. When that happens,
the entire we've known as Europe is going to suddenly unravel. And just,
you can bet that there's going to be lots of bloodshed.
Now we're stepping away from Martin Luther for a quick minute,
to talk about a brand new sponsor, promote HQ,
no matter what line of work you're in.
There's a pretty good chance that you've had to have at least one meeting online
here in 2020. Lots of people are working exclusively for all the home right now.
And depending on your job,
that trends might continue into the future for quite some time.
For many working professionals,
it's more important than ever to have a functional online meeting space.
And I don't know if I'd call myself a professional.
Having an online meeting space for me has been super important.
That's why remote HQ is so great. This isn't just another virtual space.
Hold a video call. This is a full blown online workspace.
There's tons of tools at your disposal to improve your team's functionality.
So what makes remote HQ your best option? Well,
it's got a totally customizable workspace that can be fitted with apps that best
serve your jobs purposes. Got a screen that is multi-lateral collaborative,
where anyone can just jump in, make notes or change the screen themselves,
depending on that permissions.
It's also got software that records all your sessions and lets you search
through your session notes later on, which makes backtracking even easier.
And speaking of that software, remote HQ is browser based,
which means there's no scary, questionable downloads going onto your computer.
No one likes Nass meeting rooms are also locked for authenticated users only,
which means that you don't have to worry about random teenagers,
just guessing your password and saying hello.
So all of this sounds like the missing tool that your newly remote or originally
remote team needs this year or remote HQ is going to be the solution that you
didn't even realize you need it right now,
you can use a remote hq.com forward slash biographics to start a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch use code biographics for three months free and
let's get back to today's video.
Here's the frog tassel was making the rounds was welcomed by absolutely nobody.
Frederick DWIs.
Banned him from Zack's nail though.
He couldn't stop him from operating just over the border. In spring of 15,
17 Tetzel set up shop in Jew to bog less than 40 kilometers from Wittenberg.
Now 40 kilometers in the early 16th century seems like a lot further than it
does in modern Germany of cars and auto Barnes.
But it still wasn't enough for Martin Luther that seeing tassels shameless
flogging of indulgences is just another part of the corruption had witnessed in
Rome. Luther finally snaps. He wrote out a long objection,
titled disputation on the power of indulgences.
It contains 95 objections or theses.
All of which boil down to a handful of points.
One repentance is only possible through God himself,
not through the buying of indulgences to therefore the only human path to
salvation is faith, not worldly deeds three.
So selling indulgences is just a swindle to build the Pope's new Basilica or
Azusa put it.
Why does not the Pope whose wealth today is greater than the wealth of the
richest. Crassus to the Basilica of St. Peter with his own money,
rather than with the money of poor believers. Yet, despite this criticism,
the overall tone of the 95 theses was pretty malt.
There's nothing in them to suggest that Luther knew he was writing the most
explosive documents of the last 600 years, but there's also no doubt.
Luther wanted his words to find an audience. Once he finished writing,
he sat on his work until October the 31st 1517,
the day before all saints day a day.
When thousands of pilgrims poured into Wittenberg then went down, was busy.
He marched down, took his theses to the church and enabled them to the door.
At least that's the popular version. In reality,
most scholars agree that Luther probably didn't nail his thesis. Do anything.
What he did do though, was sent copies, do a bunch of people, including fraught,
tassels, boss college, and all Albert Brandenburg.
It was these mailings that would turn a minor theological dispute into one of
the biggest events in European history. When Albert received his copy,
he was livid, not with tat sulfur. So shamelessly Hawking indulgences,
but with Luther, he forwarded this copy to Rome, demanding the Pope,
investigate this heritage monk at the same time,
other copies of Luther's 95 theses web, starting to spread across Germany.
Thanks to the relatively recent technology of the printing press new copies
could be distributed across a vast area in weeks rather than months or years
before 1517 was over Luther's work was appearing in Leipzig, Nuremberg,
and even Basel down in Switzerland. However, the Luther wasn't,
the ones spreading it.
The theses seemed to have touched a nerve one that compels people to make their
own copies for the elites.
Luthers to rate against indulgences was a useful justification for not sending
any more money to Rome, but the less wealthy it was the anti Italian sentiments.
They responded to the feeling that decent,
hardworking Germans were being fleeced by a distant and greedy Pope before long,
the theses were even being translated into German.
When Lisa found out he immediately sat about publishing his own translations by
the summer of 1518, the theses were everywhere at this stage,
the reformation wasn't yet reforming anything.
It was just a theological arguments with some political grievances attached,
this sort of thing that were Luther to play it badly or Leo the 10th to play it.
Well, it could have easily dissipated,
but if there's one thing Luther was bound to discover he was good at it.
It was playing the PR game like a.
[Inaudible].
Well, I saw my 1518 Martin Luther's name was everywhere.
His 95 theses had caught the eye of his ruler. Frederick the wise,
he seems to have realize that he could use this monk as leverage.
So when the Pope demanded Luther present himself in room to be cross-examined,
Frederick has all like, nah, my boy stays here.
We can see this either as Frederick staying true to his humanist principles or
Frederick flexing his political muscles at that moment,
the current Holy Roman emperor was on the brink of death.
Rome had its own candidates. It wants it on the throne,
but that meant not alienating electors like Frederick.
So a compromise was reached with Luther agreeing to be questioned in the German
city of Augsburg. But while this was safer than Rome,
it was still a bit dicey after just three days fled back to
Wittenberg. But before he went,
he left another document attached to the cathedral door,
insisting on his rightness over the next year.
Luther's ideas began to circulate more and more widely in a kind of domino
effect.
The more people who read his word cause the more other dissidents began writing
their own complaints.
Only these new complaints were getting a weightier and weightier challenging the
authority of the Pope himself.
But that's not to say Martin Luther was some kind of theological genius or
anything at the Leipzig debate in June of 50 19. For example,
Luther was by Johan ACC who tricked him into defending some of the
heritage Yon hostess positions.
Given the yawn hosts had been burned at the stake a century earlier.
This was not a great look for Luther,
but now the fight was just as political as it was religious on June the 28th,
15, 19, the electors made 19 year old, Charles the fifth,
Holy Roman emperor to get the gigs,
the non German Charles had to make all sorts of promises to Frederick the wise,
including an end to punishment without trial and to treat Martin Luther fairly.
It may have all been part of a plan to increase Frederick's political clouds,
but it also meant that Lusa was now effectively untouchable,
which may be why I fed up Leo the 10th finally pressed the nuclear button
on the 15th of June 15,
20 Leo issued a papal bull accusing Luther of heresy and giving him 120
days to report to Rome. Such an order was a serious, massive,
but by now Lisa had enough powerful supporters to fight back across the rest of
the year. Luther issued three pamphlets. One of them called the Pope,
the antichrist, while another written in German,
Ames do whip up the mob against Rome declaring we have the empire in name,
but the Pope has all wealth on our bodies,
lives and souls and all that we have, Oh, Nobel princess and gentlemen,
how long will you suffer your lands and your people to be the prey of
these ravening wolves?
It was rhetoric like this that made Lisa a hero to so many Germans,
but his biggest broadside came when the Pope's deadline finally ran out that
December day Luther canceled his classes, took the papal bull into it,
Wittenberg and publicly burned it.
The result was inevitable on January the third, 1521, Leo,
the 10th ex-communicated Martin Liza from the church in normal circumstances.
Excommunication was a death sentence by rights.
Luther should have been arrested by the secular authorities and burned,
but there were two problems.
The first was that Luther was now so infamous that executing him could have
triggered anything from rioting to a civil war.
The second was that Charles the fifth had promised no more punishments without a
fair hearing, something Luther patently had an hat. So once again,
a compromise was reached.
Luther would travel to the German city of worms and face the accusations that
this is all good.
As anyone who have known the meeting in worms would turn into Luther's greatest
triumph.
The showdown between Martin Luther and Charles the fifth came in April of 1521.
And it's known as the diet of worms, which comes as some pretty gross images,
but this was a Dodge in the sense of a formal meeting. And interestingly loser,
wasn't very high on the agenda.
Still that didn't stop the 30 something monk from milking it for all it was
worth. When Martin Luther left Wittenberg,
it wasn't as a lone heritage shuffling off to his fate.
It wasn't even as a confident theologians striding out to do battle.
It was as a frigging celebrities,
Johnny to worms took anything between 10 days to a month,
depending on which source you read all along the way,
Luther was treated like royalty cities through open their Gates towns,
but on welcome displays, it worms itself.
People are said to have scrambled onto rooftops to get a good look at him for
millions of Germans Luther's arguments with the church was now personal,
a David and Goliath tale about one of their own standing up to the might of
Rome. You had even amidst the triumphal procession.
Luther knew the journey might be as lost. Charles.
The fifth promised him safe passage to worms,
but the same thing had been promised to the heritage Yon horse the century
before and ended up with him being burned alive.
The auditor has ended the diet's good. Well, the death is death sentence.
Despite all the drama though, the dad worms got off to a fairly boring start.
Some business had overrun. So when Luther arrived on April the 17th,
he was made to spend nearly the entire day waiting for his case to be heard.
It was only after hours of hanging around that Luther was at last called inside
there before the emperor,
a big pile of his books had been laid out presumably to show what a heretic
wreath was. Not that the two signs went straight into arguing.
Luther was asked if it liked to recant. He asked for a day to think it over.
So everyone adjourns and got back together the next morning overnight,
where did leaked out about what was happening.
And this time the whole was jammed with spectators.
This meant Lisa had a captive audience for what would become his greatest speech
over several hours.
Luther pedantically proved by twisty logic and references to scripture.
Why it was unnecessary for him to recant his killer points was to declare the
Bible, the sole authority and say that it only retract statements.
If they could be proven wrong using scripture. Finally,
he wrapped everything up by declaring here I stand. God, help me.
I can do no other well. Supposedly in reality,
this now famous statement was probably added later by biographers still.
It was a grand performance in response Johns,
the phaser requested a day to think things over.
Is it multiple to imagine how it felt being in Germany for that long night and
nights?
When the future of many of the Holy Roman empire state seems to hang in the
balance of lost on April the 19th, Charles declared had reached his decision.
Luther was a heretic and should be put to death boss in a major twist.
Charles also announced that he was upholding his promise of safe conduct. So,
but as long as Luther remained in worms, while the dye was in session,
he would be unharmed.
It was an active clemency that gave Luther supporters all the time they needed
on April the 26th, 1521 Martin Luther was kidnapped just outside worms.
Almost everyone assumes this had been taken on the Pope's orders and probably
murdered,
but no instead Frederick the wise and arranged for Luther to be spirited away to
a remote castle,
where he was given a false identity and placed into hunting that he remains for
around a year quietly working on a translation of the Bible into German while
the world outside went crazy. By the time new ther surfaced in March of 1522,
the reformation would already be underway.
Key reasons.
The reformation exploded after the diet of worms is that it was never just a
religious issue while who followed Lee. So, uh, and it for the scriptural stuff,
plenty more. We're excited by as anti Italian stances as well.
Plenty more just saw an opportunity to shake things up a bit.
All swaths of German princess, for example,
were encouraged to support lethal purely because doing so demonstrated their
independence from the emperor and shorts.
It was the society-wide shakeups sort of how the explosion of populism in our
own time turned everything on its head,
but times a million or one ends of the spectrum.
You had things like the Augustinian FRAs,
Western bags smashing up their own altarpieces and throwing off the cloth at the
other. You had the peasants war,
which ignited in 1524 and saw farmers rampaging across central Germany,
fighting for increased political rights under the convenient banner of
Lutheranism in between. There were rods,
new religious ordinances and serious reform methods that completely transformed
parts of Europe.
And that's not even mentioning the other reformers who appeared in Luther's wake
like whole drink Swingley down in Zurich or John Calvin in Geneva.
Yes. Even as the reformation get up into a cultural transformation,
Luther's part in, it was already drawing to a close post worms.
His role became ever more peripheral. The change hastened by some bad decisions.
For example, Islam,
lambasting of the peasants wall were seen by some of his followers to be a
betrayal of his own work and alienated many.
There was also bad luck such as Frederick, the wise, his death in 1525,
which robs Luther of his greatest patron.
Still Lisa never quite managed to slip into total obscurity.
He still works on his German translation of the Bible,
a project that would help codify the rest in German language.
He also took part in drafting, the Augsburg confession,
the 1530 document that solidified the splits between Lutherans and reformists,
although it was far from the only author,
but mostly he settled down marrying an ex naan and slowly drifting into ever
matter theories. That was his growing anti-Semitism for example,
which saw him cool for pogroms and the burning of Jewish homes and texts.
So vitriolic later inspired the Nazis less violence,
but also OD was his public support for polygamy, for his non horny,
non antisemitic admirers. This was embarrassing in the extreme.
You can always hear them quietly rooting for him to just get on with us and dies
or they can focus on the good stuff and ignore the crazy racist uncle shtick.
Mozley finally obliged them on February the 18th, 1546 dead at age 62,
he was buried in the same, which in bag church,
it's supposedly nailed his 95 theses to nearly 30 years earlier.
By this time,
his effect on history was already undeniable just before his death.
The council of trends had convened kicking off the counter reformation.
A decade later in 1555,
the peace of Augsburg would formally recognize Protestants in the Holy Roman
empire,
allowing each individual ruler to choose between Lutheranism and Catholicism for
his people. But this would just be hitting the pause button. 60 years later,
the unresolved tensions of the era would explode into the religious chaos of the
30 years.
War per capita is still one of the deadliest Wars ever fought by then though
Martin Luther was just a memory today is near impossible to overstate.
Just how important this one monk was.
Protestantism remains one of the biggest branches of Christianity on earth
itself by far the biggest religion. Well,
not every Protestant denomination has a positive view of Luther.
It was only thanks to his actions or in reactions to them that many of them ever
got started. But even when you strip away the religious aspects,
Luther remains of buying to a figure in the six or so years when he was at his
most prominent,
this one's obscure monk laid the foundations of the future of central and
Western Europe. Some of that was unquestionably good.
Some of it is like the 30 years war was questionably horrific,
but most it's simply just wants the reformation.
Luther sparked is by now. So apart of the Western world's DNA,
that it's impossible to imagine a timeline in which never happens.
Martin Luther may have simply been in the right place at the right time to spark
these changes, but it was his own character.
That's allowed things to play out as they did for better and for worse,
we are still living in a world shaped by his actions.
So if you found that video interesting, if you did,
please do smash that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to check it out.
Fantastic sponsor HQ link below. And thank you for watching.